pas la catastrophe aérienne du boeing
747 de la panam les coudes des fameuses
boîtes noires qui enregistrent
normalement toutes les données du vol
n'a malheureusement rien révélé
d'intéressant quant à la nature de
l'accident ou de l'attentât cas les deux
hypothèses restent envisageables même si
celle de l'attentât reste privilégiée
sur place notre envoyé spécial philippe
harrouard un look by noël ne sera pas
tout à fait noël tels que les deux mille
habitants la dette imaginer leur virée
tu es trop bouleversée et pourtant il
faut faire face la population de la
petite villa doublé avec les équipes de
recherche les militaires les
travailleurs sociaux les journalistes et
puis les familles des victimes
américaines dont certaines ont tenu un
passé ce noël non loin de leurs proches
disparus
tout a été fait pour qu'il puisse loger
dignement à l'occ bus ou dans les
environs leur peine et partager les
prêtres réconforte partout où cela est
nécessaire
les corps de tous les passagers n'ont
pas été retrouvés les 600 personnes
chargées de leurs recherches vont
poursuivre leur pénible tâche demain et
les jours suivants plusieurs cadavres
sont encore manquants
d'autres équipes s'activent à collecter
les débris qui seront analysés par les
experts eux seuls permettront de dire
s'il ya eu sabotage puisque la boîte
noire de l'avion n'a rien révélé
d'anormal sauf un léger bruit la zone de
recherche était tendu certaines pièces
du boeing ont été retrouvés à 50 km de
l'ocs b dans la petite ville écossaise
on pleure 17 morts habitant tous la même
rue sherwood cresson qui a été rasée par
une aile du boeing plein de kérosène en
feu et la ramsden habitait ici au numéro
quand sa maison s'est écroulée sous zèle
on la croyait morte par une chance
extraordinaire
elle a survécu j'étais dans ma cuisine
raconte elle est soudain j'ai cru que
c'était la fin du monde il y avait plus
de toi je pouvais voir le ciel j'ai
cassé une vitre
j'ai pu sortir il y avait un silence
extraordinaire plus personne et la ram
zen son chien et son perroquet vivent ce
soir à lockerbie
le miracle de noël